donc il ya une lettre où ou la dernière
phrase n'est un petit peu inquiété je me
suis dit est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse
quelque chose ou pas ne pouvant pas le
contacter par téléphone à la prison j'ai
pris l'initiative de devenir en parler
parce que il me dit dans sa dernière
phrase que la mort pourrait être une
délivrance parce que ils en bavent
voilà d'être entre quatre murs depuis
quatre mois alors qu'il est présumé
innocent qui n'a pas été jugé encore et
voilà je respecte quels sont les infos
sur son séjour en prison les infos il me
dit que les dix minutes ce ensemble des
heures donc ça c'est normal il me dit
ensuite qu'il a une heure de balade de
promenade dans la cour ça c'est normal
comme pour tout le monde et puis mais sa
dernière phase jean-luc c'est un mec qui
est mentalement qui était assez fort
comme hong kong 1 parce que ce qui subit
il assez fort je tiens à dire aussi que
je le connais depuis 25 ans 30 ans je
l'aï vu souvent avec des jeunes femmes
mais c'étaient des femmes c'étaient des
jeunes eux je n'ai jamais vu avec une
petite des nattes et une barbe à papa
mais bon heureusement norme est ce que
je veux dire c'est que c'est pas du tout
non plus
j'avais envie de dire que j'avais 15 ans
je ne fais pas des celui d'une femme
c'est des jeunes filles je suis pas venu
traiter sur le point je suis venu juste
alerter mais c'est une affaire qui a 10
ans moi je le connais bien depuis dix
ans je sait vraiment qui faisait très
très attention même quand il se faisait
draguer parce qu'il se draguer tout il a
toujours fait très très attention
l'afer qui a 10 ans où il avait eu
certainement du sursis
est revenu maintenant il ya eu à
l'époque mais maintenant que pour rien
c'est lors mireille apollon alors ce
qu'il faut savoir quand même c'est que
donc jean legrez depuis le 5 novembre
est incarcéré à la prison de la santé
dans un quartier vip et il est accusé
quand même de viol de plusieurs
agressions de sexuel est également de
subordination de témoins et de
détournement de mineur par rapport à la
sphère qui s'est passé c'est sur la
première victime s'il est actuellement
en détention c'est parce qu'il ya eu des
pressions sur ses différentes et moi et
que c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il est
en prison il est pas en prison pour rien
voilà alors il est accusé de viol mais
il lui dit qu'il ya jamais eu viol il ya
eu consentement mais comme il faudrait
juger les affaires et assure le contexte
de l'époque il ya aussi dans les dents
les chefs d'inculpation est aussi abus
de faiblesse puisque c'étaient des
jeunes voilà une emprise à blaise et
abus de faiblesse il le transforme en
violent parce que abus de faiblesse non
elle était avec elle et inertie aux
influences t elle j'étais fan
forcément
soulagé que pour la première victime qui
a aujourd'hui à d a déposé plainte à
l'époque en 2000
dans les années 2013 en fait elle avait
il y avait eu en 2010 il avait été
accusé d'autre part par fin facebook
modérateurs de facebook avait dé vouloir
aider quand même des vidéos
pornographiques avec cette jeune fille
qui était mineur au moment des faits etc
il avait eu du sursis parce que
justement dépression avait été fait sur
ce témoin afin qu'elle ne témoigne pas
et c'est pour ça qu'il s'en était sorti
à l'époque et aujourd'hui la sphère est
revenue puisqu'il ya eu d'autres
éléments dans l' enquête qui sont quand
même assez gravissime impliquant
également les deux mamans des deux
victimes présumées et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui mais en prison alors
j'entends j'entends ce que vous dites
vous parler en tant qu' ami mais alors
la lettre la lettre vincent nous
apporter la lettre il avait reçu signé
de jean luc lahaye il dit mon vincent tu
sais je ne sais absolument pas quand je
retrouverai ma liberté ici je ne suis
plus rien au mur et 23 heures sur 24
j'ai droit à une heure de marche dans
une cour au mur entouré de barbelés en
fait une heure de matin et une heure
l'après midi une heure le matin et dans
l'après-midi pour si je suis dans un
vrai cauchemar je commence à sombrer peu
à peu je ne sais pas combien de temps je
vais tenir chaque minute dure une heure
c'est à se demander si la mort ne serait
pas une délivrance merci pour ton
soutien je t'embrasse fort mont vinson
jean luc lahaye